Nik vile and fiance Vanessa Grimaldi's  relationship is put to the test on Jimmy  Kimmel Live what we're gonna do here is  play the newly-engaged game The Bachelor  stars made their second television  appearance together Monday night where  Jimmy subjected them to a little game on  how well they actually know one another  you tell us where did you and your  fiance first make love your answers have  to match so please no peeking  Nick says the newly engaged couple also  dished on Nick's next adventure Dancing  with the Stars  was that something you had to discuss  before you agreed very supportive yeah I  was really excited about the whole you  know Dancing with the Stars experience  and he rented by me we spoke about it  and yeah I think like he does a great  dancer I'm really happy that he got to  be paired up with Peeta yeah putting  myself in this  [Music]